sapete cosa sto facendo non ha yoga si
chiamano bauer pose e lo spiega molto
bene e amica di che una ricercatrice di
harvard e servono per farci più grandi
di fronte a situazioni di pericolo lo
fanno gli animali quando sono spaventati
si ingrandiscono lo facciamo noi quando
dobbiamo affrontare delle situazioni
difficili e lo si fa anche davanti agli
orsi in consiglio di vita nel caso vi
trovate davanti a un orso fatevi più
grossi sono modi che utilizziamo tramite
il nostro corpo per ingannare il nostro
cervello per farci credere di essere
capaci di superare situazioni difficili
ma non è vero siamo le stesse persone di
prima
siamo le stesse persone con le stesse
paure però facendo così ci auto
convinciamo che siamo grandi abbastanza
per affrontare un pericolo e forse
qualcuno di voi piano ma visto in giro
facevo queste mosse strane sembrava un
cretino
una volta che ho ingannato me stesso
forse era volta gli inganni più grandi
per raccontato me stesso è proprio
quello di un filo che vedete di su è
infatti devo chiedere scusa al pubblico
devo chiedere scusa ai organizzato
questo talk perché non sono un
giornalista non
non ho mai studiato per fare il
giornalista non ho nessun titolo per
farlo non sono iscritto all'albo non
sono iscritto a nessun sindacato come si
usa in inghilterra
eppure in qualche maniera
sono stato pubblicato da quello che per
me il miglior giornale al mondo il
giornale più importante al mondo che al
guardian e mi hanno pubblicato una
storia riguardo ai cittadini a cinesi
che cercava di sfruttare le nuove
tecnologie per guadagnare libertà di
parola e lì ho iniziato a dire che o li
jarmila con dicevo per un giornalista ma
non era vero
non era un giornalista non avevo
studiato per farlo questo sono io nel
2013 coi dredd assomigliamo molto meno
fabio volo di quanto se migliora e drive
fino al fondoschiena indossava un abito
a giacca e cravatta per convincermi di
essere un businessman per convincermi di
essere in grado di interpretare il ruolo
che avevo all'epoca che era quello di
rappresentare una compagnia di ricerche
di mercato in italia la compagnia
inglese e così come raccontava tino
prima ti metti un naso da clown diventi
un clown la maschera vi corre al mondo
ma anche prima si raccontava durante
l'esplorazione arti che il modo per
convincerci di superare un pericolo in
quel preciso istante io mi stavo
convincendo di essere un esperto di
social media ma in realtà non lo erano
lo sapevo ero inganno stavo era un
impostore
avevo dei dati che però dimostravano
quello che dicevo il mio figlio mi
diceva massiva ai anche se non sei un
esperto non ti preoccupare se hai dei
dati per sostenere quello che dici
nessuno può contraddirti sei un esperto
ma non era un esperto e allora come sono
arrivato a poter dire a poter essere qua
e dire che sono giornalista ingannare
tutta queste persone durante uno di
questi convegni
stefano epifani che un professore della
della sapienza mi diede mi venne anche
essere di chiedere di scrivere sul media
che stava lanciando che hi tech economy
e fu un primo inizio degli iniziai a
scrivere a lui mi chiese di scrivere in
qualità di esperto e io dissi
sicuramente certo ma non era un esperto
stavo ingannando me stesso
volevo iniziare a fare il giornalista
perché quello era il mio sogno fin da
piccolo io volevo diventare un
giornalista
perciò proiettavo di fronte a me una
persona che sarei voluto diventare
guardavo il marcello del futuro lo
vedevo giornalista dice voi un giorno
diventerò marcello diventerò quel
marcello giornalista ma non lo ero
vedrete che konami passo è stato breve
arrivare anche futuro che il blog
all'epoca era il blog più influente in
italia per quanto riguardava
l'innovazione fondato da riccardo luna
che l'attuale digital champion da lì
sono arrivato wired per una serie di
vicissitudini e ho sfruttato un pochino
il conflitto interno che c'era tra che
futuro e wired e anzi c'è una storia
molto carina perché poi la storia di
wired non andò a finire benissimo perché
l'articolo che vedete che si vede lin in
parte ii c log era un articolo riguardo
agli spazi di coworking a londra che è
un un trend che sta crescendo e che però
la redazione di wired.it mi aveva
rifiutato non è però non ci interessa
secondo me invece era un pezzo molto
valido lo pubblicai lo stesso e lo
pubblicai nello stesso giorno che loro
chiudevano in cui loro chiudevano
l'edizione cartacea del giornale e
cambiava la direttore quindi il tempismo
peggiore che si potesse immaginare
e questo mi costò rapporto con wired per
un po di mesi finché non cambia il
direttore ancora e adesso è recentemente
riallacciato da wired a start up italia
che il magazine più importante in italia
per quanto riguarda il mondo delle
startup sul quale racconto storie di
imprenditori e dopo arriva a raccontare
cosa questo ha a che fare con tutto il
concetto da start up italia a techcrunch
the clans è il blog più grande al mondo
sono l'unico italiano che scrive su
techcrunch
ma ancora una volta non sono un
giornalista non sono un esperto ma
volevo farlo mi sono imposto di
diventare ciò che volevo diventare mai
ingannato alla mia mente mi sono fatto
più grande di quello che in realtà ero
c'è un concetto in inglese che
che spiega molto bene appunto amica di
che si chiama fe kit until you make it
cioè fingi finché non diventi ciò che
vuoi diventare il mio talks i chiamati
art of pretending l'arte di immaginare
di essere che vuoi essere l'arte di
essere un impostore immaginati e lo
diventerà i sei uno studio
dell'università del misure del 2009 che
dice che la confidenza cioè credere noi
stessi ha un impatto drammatico sulle
nostre performance più crediamo in noi
stessi più diventiamo bravi più fingiamo
che riusciamo a diventare ciò che
vogliamo essere un impatto
la cosa di una forza dirompente un'altra
cosa che dicono gli inglesi a fei
confidence to gain influence finge di
credere in te stesso per guadagnare
influenza è l'unico modo che hai ma
tutto questo non l'ho fatto perché sono
il giornalista non l'ho fatto perché non
ho aspettato che qualcuno mi
riconoscesse il titolo di chiamarmi
giornalista se avessi dovuto aspettare
quel titolo
probabilmente sarà ancora poi a marcire
sarei ancora qua a sognare di diventare
quello che volevo diventare e anzi
ricordo un episodio ero all'università e
facevo la tesi con quello che all'epoca
era tuttora forse famoso professore di
scienza politica in italia che per non
rivelare il nome chiamerò gianfranco p
anche se fosse più facile chiamarlo g
pasquino però va bene non sarebbe
corretto dire nel nome e mi ricordo che
stavo camminando per le scale
dell'università di bologna che questo
palazzo imponente 1300 esco e incrociamo
per le scale pietro ichino giuslavorista
consigliere del governo io e un altro
mio collega tesista e il professore e
ichino chiese al professore ma come sono
questi ragazzi sono bravi ha scritto no
non ce la faranno mai non riusciranno
mai non hanno idea di quello che li
aspetta che è un bel messaggio per dei
ragazzi di 25 anni che stanno cercando
di costruirsi la carriera questa è una
cosa che in italia si tende a fare a
tutti i livelli cercano di spezzarti le
gambe non devi credere in te stesso ab
paura di quello che ti aspetta perché
non hai idea di quello che ti aspetta
quello che io dico al contrario e lo
dico perché anni anni dopo ebbi la
fortuna di tornare a studiare negli
stati uniti dopo semestre che fece al
liceo già la prima esperienza mi insegna
che che gli americani puntano tutto sul
convincerti di riuscire a superare i
pericoli sul convincersi di potercela
fare
ai corsi all'università benché fossero
molto più semplici dei corsi che facevo
nella verità italiana non facevano altro
che insegna arti e sci che le aziende
cercano gente come te eh sì che il mondo
ti sta aspettando esci che ce la farai
tutto il concetto che loro hanno intorno
agli sport e l'individualismo il gioco
di squadra e tutto bene vogliono
convincerti che tu ce la farai non hanno
una preparazione migliore della nostra
ma loro ce la fanno
noi invece si spezzano le alici spezzano
le gambe in continuazione
l'ultima volta che ho ingannato me
stesso è stato domenica scorsa eccomi
qua questo sono io domenica scorsa all
ha la tendenza ad addormentarvi imposti
quando quando sono in situazioni di
tensione e pericolo qua stavo dormendo
su un balcone il giorno stesso in cui
avrei dovuto provare per preparare
questo discorso
ho ingannato me stesso di poter essere
in grado di essere qui davanti a voi a
parlarvi di avere qualcosa di
interessante da dire
mi hanno proposto mi hanno chiesto vuoi
fare il talk a ted
certo ovviamente ma non sapevo se lo
potevo fare
non sapevo cosa aveva da raccontarvi
eppure accettato perché ho visto me
stesso in questa situazione una
settimana fa ho ingannato me stesso ho
pensato di potercela fare ed era una
cosa che ho sempre voluto fare il solo
ingannato mi sono visto in questa
situazione ed eccomi qua davanti a voi e
questo sono io che dormo terrorizzato
sul palco ho finto di essere un ted
speaker richard branson probabilmente il
più grande imprenditore che ci sia al
mondo in questo momento dice il sun
vario fusion amazing opportunity bacio a
nocciolo candoi 6 us dell'earn out to it
later
se qualcuno vi offre un'opportunità
incredibile e non siete sicuri di
potercela fare e dite di sì
imparerete dopo a fare le cose che
dovete fare
non bisogna aver paura feki until you
make it finge di essere ciò che vuoi
diventare eventualmente lo diventerà i
nel 2014
mi sono trovato in questa situazione il
vecchio cianci di mackie della
situazione che viene utilizzato anche in
psicologia per aiutare persone in
depressione a immaginarsi al di fuori
della situazione di crisi nella quale
sono nel 2014
il mondo minimi crollo dosso e gli ho
mandato londra una persona con questa
passione da due anni e con la quale
manda è convivere per altri tre anni
quindi cinque anni di vita assieme
penso di conoscere una persona come le
tue tasche e invece accidentalmente
scoprì che questa persona aveva aveva
una seconda vita una vita parallela
della pallina non era assolutamente a
conoscenza soprattutto quando si è
all'estero sia lontano dai propri cari
se lontano dai propri amici esiste
attacca delle persone che diventano un
pochino le aree quella di salvezza lei
era la mia venuta a mancare questa
ancora il mondo è crollato a me crollato
addosso mi sono trovato per sei mesi è
sdraiato su un divano e non riuscivo sia
da privati fissavo soffitto e non ce la
facevo a uscire dalla mia zona di
confort e la mia zona di confronto in
quel momento lì era il mio divano era
molto il set in crisi le nostre zone di
comfort sono sempre più ristrette quando
invece siamo nel pieno di comfort e
piante dobbiamo espandere la zona di
comfort più che uscirne espanderla
perché dobbiamo essere in grado di
immaginarci essere in grado di uscire da
questa zona quindi con la volontà pian
piano spingere i volti della sala di
comfort in questa maniera sono riuscito
a uscire da questa crisi solamente
perché riuscivo a immaginarmi al di
fuori solamente perché vedevo quel
marcello capace di riuscire a uscire da
questa crisi ma non sapevo di potercela
fare quello che stavo al di fuori del
divano mi terrorizzava non sapevo se ci
riuscivo non lo sapevo convinto me
stesso ho ingannato il mio cervello per
farci ma attenzione perché non vuol dire
essere degli impostori non vuol dire a
diventare dei chirurghi senza saper cosa
fare non vuol dire improvvisarsi un
astronauta vecchi can see you make it è
il concetto di poter diventare la
persona che si vuole essere smettere di
aspettare incominciare a fare in
cominciare subito
vivo a londra da cinque anni è una città
estremamente multiculturale solamente
noi italiani siamo 500.000 è la quarta
città italiana più grande al mondo 500
mila italiani che hanno lasciato le loro
sicurezze
è una situazione che evidentemente
immaginava una strada difficile per
inseguire un sogno per cercare di
realizzare qualcosa senza però conoscere
ciò che li aspettava escono dalla loro
comfort son sperando di riuscire a
diventare le persone che vorrebbero
diventare creano fanno sognano io
racconto le storie di queste persone sul
su start up italia che è il blog di cui
vi parlavo prima
e sono tutte storie di ragazzi che in
qualche modo magari mollano le loro
sicurezze lavorative ricordiamoci che la
maggior parte di imprenditori vi ragazzi
quelli che chiamiamo start upper magari
non ha lasciato dei lavori siano molto
ben pagati o magari hanno lasciato le
loro sicurezze perché vogliono diventare
qualcuno perché si immagina nella
situazione immagino le persone che
vorrebbero diventare credono i loro
stessi a tal punto di potersi
visualizzare in quella situazione
mollano tutto e lo vanno a fare alla
stessa maniera
gestisco un meet up che raduna oltre
1.500 persone che lavorano nella
tecnologia a londra ed è un meet up che
funziona supporto della comunità
italiana
gli imprenditori italiani vengono a
raccontare le loro storie di successo
per essere ispirazione agli altri che
gli vogliono seguire che vogliono
seguire loro il loro esempio
e questa una forza tanta una forza
enorme perché queste persone riescono a
vedersi in queste persone di successo e
quindi si immaginano loro fingono il
loro cervello di poter diventare quelle
persone fakeav ancilli make it
pretendono di diventare quelle persone
qualche mese fa qualcuno ha attaccato
questa frase sul muro di casa mia
vice forget sexting il guaio fear to
live and destroy all and protection b
notorious dimentica la zona di sicurezza
la tua zona di sicurezza vivido hai
paura di vivere
distruggi la tua reputazione diventa
famoso diventa note perché questa cosa
importante in questo periodo della mia
vita
raggiunti questi traguardi e raggiunto
il fatto di scrivere sul blog più grande
raggiunto il fatto di essere ater
speaker avendo una volta che ho formato
una piccola zona di confort e così come
mi è successo in tutta la mia vita
quando mi trovo in una zona di confort
io mi trovo in qualche maniera non a mio
agio per qualche ragione ho deciso di
cambiare
prendo e butto via tutto quello che ho
costruito fino adesso tranne la mia
esperienza interiore delle quali non mi
posso liberare vendo tutto quello che
posseggo distruggo la mia reputazione
con la quale sono stato esso senato
troppo tempo e al gennaio prendo e parto
per un viaggio in asia di minimo sei
mesi durante il quale non ho idea di
cosa farò
non ho idea come mi guadagnava da vivere
ma so che ce la posso fare ho visto al
presidente riuscire a farlo mi marmi mi
immedesimo in queste persone e faccio
finta di essere quella persona fin che
eventualmente non la di vento
so che ce la farò sa o per riuscire a
guadagnarmi da vivere in qualche modo
perché ho fiducia in me stesso perché mi
sono convinto il mio cervello di
potercela fare
quindi vecchi consigli make it
perciò non è più il caso di aspettare e
la prossima volta che abbiamo dei dubbi
la prossima volta che abbiamo delle
insicurezze la passata che vogliamo
intraprendere un viaggio importante
un'avventura che non siamo felici
ricordatevi di convincere il vostro
cervello si fanno due power pop si fa
quella che si chiama la posa da wonder
woman funziona aumenta il livello di
testosterone è stato privato chiudete
gli occhi e f kin sirio make it grazie